when you got your teeth done yeah
did you do it here or did you go to a
different country I did it here oh you
did yeah yeah yeah and these are
actually Temporaries that are going to
be for people who don't know because are
you are you doing the implants yeah
these These are so right now is a bridge
I have a bridge on top and a bridge on
the bottom it's not like Dentures I
can't tell you you're gonna get like
full implants right yeah yeah and so
you're not even getting veneers no no no
no no no
boys yeah yeah I have no teeth left on
the top or the bottom in between my
canines they cemented a bridge in so
temporary that's there and um I'll just
tell you you're gonna be out for a while
I'll tell you this though bootleg Kev
the [__] quotient is through the roof
good for you man knocking them down
there I'm glad to hear it I'm knocking
them down where are you finding them
Reddit they finding me they finding me
it's crazy like I I don't know I was
about to say Jesus Christ we got to get
this Velcro
you got to get a cemented like my damn
teeth for sure I was gonna say I always
uh what a note or no jumper groupies or
or battle rap groupies are they like
what kind of T because I always say the
ugliest groupies in the world are
Juggalos yeah yeah like icps groupies
God bless them just talk about [__] it's
speaking of meth Jesus Christ yeah I'm
not trying to have an orgy at the
Gathering yeah no disrespect to the my
Juggalos you feeling yeah shout outs I
love y'all
whoop whoop have you been to the
Gathering I have not I would love to go
to the Gathering I hear there's a drug
tent yeah or no there's a drug bridge I
believe it and then there's like a TP
where there's just a [__] in there you
gang the orgy the orgy 10. what's that
smell like
welfare
Bumblebee tuna child molestation yeah
like a kind of a baby of all that yeah
27 year old chicken there got [__] by
her uncle and her brother at once and
now she's getting [__] by now she's
got a uncle and Patrick man tattooed on
her neck right but I would say there's
there's [__] second grade teachers in
this world right now with Hatchet Man
statute on their body you know that's
actually considered a gang in very right
yeah and there's like in certain States
like Utah
foreigners but they're in Utah in Utah
there was some Juggalo wound up killing
a Sereno oh and now there's a [__]
green light on the jungle in the Utah
Penitentiary system for anybody with the
hatchet man tag
so I've been told so the South cider's
got beef with the Juggalos in Utah yes
and I don't know if that's still a thing
but this was yeah that's interesting
yeah what are the Mormons and you can
uh they're Juggalo Mormons or South side
Mormons I don't know but and just to
make it clear this is not something that
I'm bringing to the internet this is
something that's already known if you
you know tap into different places Utah
have you have you ever done a battle on
YouTube I've been to Salt Lake yeah it's
cool it's fun out there is it it is but
as far as groupies I'll tell you this no
jumper groupies are levels beyond the
battle rap group yeah yeah they are yeah
I gotta be honest can you imagine the
kind of chick that just is like every
battle she's there just by yourself
there's like some cute ones so I'm not
gonna lie like we you know like there's
some cute battle rap chicks but it's
definitely like the the [__] that are
the [__] that are in
into no jumper a lot of them were
aspiring only fans models you know what
I mean like did you ever get any porn
chick [__] over there oh yeah yeah oh
yeah just just being over there oh yeah
absolutely nice yeah anybody we can talk
about nothing I can no you know what I
don't wanna do you ever take on the
Asian chick with the ass look here's no
I did not but here's the thing if I wind
up Kazumi yeah yeah you never [__]
zoomy look no but like if I did I
wouldn't say because here's the thing
right that makes me look super lame I'm
not gonna fair not gonna speak on my
dick and then yeah but other [__]
that might be interested in throwing me
some [__] they might judge you based on
your body oh this dude got a big mouth
accumulative body count too the body
counts one thing but like he's he's
gonna put me on blast
I will never put you on blast baby girl
so you're single I'm single currently
good for you man yeah yeah well listen
man I was heartbroken last year you feel
me I got a respect was that your fiance
that was my which one because you said
your fiancee was that who broke your
heart uh well I kind of it was my fault
let me put this [__] thing off yeah
yeah please pause
um so so you were supposed to get
married yes didn't work out didn't work
out who knows what the future holds yeah
but yeah that's what's up man well look
I'm glad you're sober appreciate it stay
sober and know it's a tough journey man
absolutely you go to meetings every week
I do I do several times a week she get
the coins and all that yep got my three
year coin about a month in the house my
sobriety birthday is February 3rd wow
well congrats man stay sober buddy got
you and keep uh just one thing I'll tell
you man is I know it's very easy and we
already talked about this a bit earlier
don't pay attention to the comments and
don't pay attention to what anybody else
is doing because I'm sure it's easy to
look over and be like oh [__] this is
happening over here this is how just
worry about building your own [__] Brick
by Brick don't compare Dixon to gangbang
for sure you feel me but with that being
said
with that being said Kev um it's been
it's cool to actually chop it up it's
usually get to know you you feel me yes
sir you might have more in common than
uh I initially even thought we're both
old white dudes who like rap music yeah
you feel me how old are you I'm 41. okay
I'm 36. so we're you know we're yeah
yeah yeah well you know yeah we
definitely are both just old dusty
hip-hop you feel me spinning Dusty
pieces of wax you know the Vibes come on
appreciate your brother man yeah you as
well sir boom